good morning uh secretary general will
deliver some remarks to you on the
ongoing warning today
thank you very much for your presence
one month ago
the russian federation launched a
massive invasion of the sovereign
territory of ukraine
in violation of the u.n charter
it was done after months of building up
a military force of overwhelming
proportion along the ukrainian border
since then
we have seen appalling human suffering
and destruction
in cities towns and villages
systematic bombardments that terrorize
civilians
the shelling of hospitals schools
apartment buildings and shelters
and all of it is intensifying
getting more destructive and more
unpredictable by the hour
10 million ukrainians have been forced
from their homes and are on the move
but the war is going nowhere fast
for more than two weeks
mario paul has been encircled by the
russian army and relentlessly bombed
shelled and attacked
for what
even if mario paul falls ukraine cannot
be conquered city by city street by
street
house by house
the only outcome to all these is more
suffering more destruction
and more horror as far as the eye can
see
the ukrainian people are enduring a
living hell and the reverberations are
being felt worldwide with skyrocketing
food
energy and fertilizer prices
threatening to spill into a global
hunger crisis
developing countries were already
suffocating under the burden of kavith
and the lack of access to adequate
financing now they are also paying a
heavy price as a result of this war
at the same time we cannot lose hope
from my outreach with various sectors
elements of diplomatic progress are
coming into view on several key issues
there is enough on the table to seize
hostilities now
and seriously negotiate now
this war is unwinnable
sooner or later it will have to move
from the battlefield to the peace table
and that is inevitable
the only question is how many more lives
must be lost
how many more bombs must fall
or many mario poles must be destroyed
or many more ukrainians and russians
will be killed
before everyone realizes that this war
has no winners only losers
or many our people will have to die in
ukraine and how many people around the
world
will have to face hunger for this to
stop
continuing the war in ukraine
is morally unacceptable
politically indefensible
and militarily nonsensical
what i said from this podium almost one
month ago
should be even more evident
today
by any measure
but even the shortest calculation
it is time to stop the fighting now
and give peace a chance
it is time to end this absurd war thank
you
secretary